Tournament
[Music]
Enteisurer, an island watched over by the gods, centered on a particularly wide central land floating in Igna,
with
the continents north, south, east and west as a cross.
A great noun of fear and cruelty in which dark creatures glide through the
demon world [Music] Satan, the demon king Satan, who has the ambition to rule the human world and
build a royal hall for all the creatures of darkness.
Coda's four
demon generals attack four continents
[Applause]
But there, one brave man rises to power
. Together with his companions, he
destroys Lucheferm in the west.
The Knights of the Allied Powers
attack the Demon King's Castle today in the central continent
[Applause]
[Music]
The two of you are wondering if it's okay for a little bit of time Beckcock is here
too I want a fan over there
Oops
, you're a foreigner Your brothers understand Japanese They look
like they're injured, but they had a fight
No,
about leaving
]
I haven't seen much around here,
but I
'm Sasaki, the person in charge.
Thisis Katsudon
OK for active sounds
yes yes yes
[music] Beast
meat covered with cereals and
soaked in lucky oil Mash
up a bird's egg and put it on top Take
a
sea bream and heat it up again Well,
this is really no good  But you're the
victims, and it's
my treat
[Music] It's
no good, I'll come in without permission
Oh,
my
partner,
Ueki  The apostle is Tokyo, which is now here
, and this building
seems to be a place called a police station.The
police seem to be one of the national institutions that protect the order of society.
extremely common dishes  I
see, it
sounds powerful
Eh, no, this isn't that important In
this world, existences like magic, magic,
demon kings, and demons are all fictional
and don't exist
.  Music]
I see,
so we can't maintain our devil
form because of a lack of
magical power.  The playfulness is
probably due to this world and the action of the gate
I still have some magical power left It
's hard to stop the flow of my bones
, so how about
you?
The problem is that
there
is no way to store it again.
It may be
that the only way left for us is to find the means
to recover our magical powers.Until then, we have no choice but
to follow the rules of this human being and live in this
world.What a harsh reality.
Get your
family register and resident card at the ward office
Yes,
next is to open a bank account
and use this God is the currency of this country.
We are looking for a house.We are looking for
a property under any conditions.The
landlord here is a
very
good deal.
This is Room 201.
You are the two people who want to move in this time
. The owner of this apartment also lives next door.  I'm
Mickey.I wrote that Miki shines beautifully, but
feel free
to call me MickeyDemon Lord, are you
really glad you're here?
Maou-sama
Let's take a new step from here
King
Maou-sama
Maou-sama  It's a human body, so it's necessary to
do something, and moreover, that natural enemy is
said to be equivalent to one month's rent in the Devil's Castle
in this country.
According to what I've heard, in
this human society,
money is the most necessary and indispensable thing.
You idiot Direcso isn't just for nothing, okay
Satan Sadao and Yoshiya Shiroko's name change,
right?
I'm
not
saying that you need a refrigerator before summer, and a
washing machine is cheaper than a laundromat in the long run.
I opened a loan, right
? Paying in installments will cost a fee.
Are you planning on not eating until payday?
It's a super size okay?
If you don't mind, use it,
because my part-time job is right there.
I'll do it Have
you decided on your order
Cheeseburger and cola S size
Would you like some black pepper fries together during the campaign period
?
I'll keep 0 yen.
Chicken burger and iced coffee Happiness
set
will be 730 yen.
Also, if you don't mind, can
you use the microwave?
[Music]
Well then, can I ask you
something?  It's going to be
cool.It's a part-time
job, but I
've lost my multicolor.Please
call me Ashi or Ar Ciel
.
I'm sure you're
right, but you
searched for
a way
to regain your magical powers.  If there is a way, when
I regain my magical power,
I will rule not only Enteisra, but also this world, wo
n't I?
I said [music],
but
today the newcomers are
excellent
, aren't they completely underlings?
[Music] It's an
earthquake It's the
devil himself
Yeah, that's right
Chii-chan
Everyone makes mistakes It's the
sixth
time I've scattered potatoes on the floor
I'm cleaning when
I'm doing it At this rate, potatoes will grow from the floor
Hey,
what's wrong with the young people who are
taking a break?
This is where the fight for 1st place comes in. I'm
begging you, and keep the potato rolls in moderation.
Sasaki
Yes,
tuna burger
please.
It hasn't risen yet It's not the time to
say that it's only Black Pepper What should I do?
It's not Mao-san's fault, and it
looks like it will be repaired in time for the night.
Did you suspect that I tried to use magic
just now?
After that, I went to your store
.
[Music]
Why are you
working part-time at
McGronald? Santa Emilia, the demon king [Music] Where does the morning come from?  If you're a
liar and a coward, gather them all together, if it's
me I'm a
dreamless hermit in
the shadows of today
Dana
[music]